this will cover some old ground and I
apologize in advance to those who
recognize familiar themes and perhaps
even familiar phrases but not 36 hours
after it was said the monstrosity and
the evil of Donald Trump's refusal to
commit to honoring the election outcome
during the third election debate has
come into even sharper focus it is in
short the greatest existential threat to
this country's government since the
Cuban Missile Crisis
it is easily the greatest internal
existential threat to this country's
government since the Civil War and it is
by itself the worst moment of
governmental instability and
vulnerability since 9/11 and Donald
Trump's apologists continue to pretend
it doesn't matter or didn't happen or it
was no worse than Al Gore's challenge in
2000 or any of a dozen other nonsensical
excuses that can only be even remotely
rationalized by a fat paycheck because
they have no grounding in reality no
grounding in democracy no grounding and
what was actually said and recorded at 6
minutes and 38 seconds past 7 o'clock
Pacific Daylight Time in Las Vegas
Nevada on the night of October 19th 2016
the exact moment at which the clock
began to run out on the Republican
Party's opportunity to disconnect itself
from a man whose petulance and arrogance
hit its peak and began to subvert our
fair and free elections the comparison
to the gore challenge is particularly
venal no one commenting on the political
scene has as much personal anguish about
and disappointment with Al Gore as I do
but that doesn't change the fact that
the 2000 election and the gore V Bush
Supreme Court case bear no resemblance
to what Donald Trump said first on
September 30th and then again twice
during the third debate none firstly
because Gore did not in any way question
the validity of as much as one vote
before Election Day Gore did not 38 days
before election day say he was
reconsidering a public pledge to honor
its outcome as Trump did in September he
did not twenty days prior to that vote
answer the question will you absolutely
accept the result of this election with
the statement I will look at it at the
time he did not two minutes later scoff
at an opportunity to back away from a
pre-emptive subversion of the democratic
process by adding I'll keep you in
suspense okay anyone whose partisanship
take such priority over their patriotism
that they can defend Trump especially
like comparing him to Gore has
symbolically burned the word liar into
their own forehead the third of trumps
campaign managers Kellyanne Conway did
so in the immediate aftermath of Trump's
second and third repetitions of the
words that will damn him throughout
American history do you remember 2000
when Al Gore contested the election she
said to a CNN reporter he actually
retracted his concession to George W
Bush Gore retracted his concession
because his aides learned he was only a
few hundred votes behind the eventual
margin of his loss there was so small
that by law they the state had to
recount the vote so much for miss Conway
trump advisor Jeff Sessions the senator
from the tree of the Keebler elves quote
Al Gore challenged the election results
and everybody has that right it was
quite a legal battle in fact the legal
challenge and the legal battle were not
initiated by gore they were provided for
by the laws of the state of Florida and
it was ultimately the Supreme Court of
the United States overruling the Supreme
Court of the state of Florida that
settled the election for Bush so much
for Senator sessions I think it's the
height of hypocrisy for Democrats now
said Trump surrogate Rudy Giuliani to
get all upset that Donald Trump said
that when it was their Democrat Al Gore
who conceded the election on election
day took it back because it was too
close then we waited two months for the
Supreme Court to decide it in fact the
entire process was concluded in five
weeks although mr. Giuliani's inference
that Gore should not have bothered to
wait for a decision by the highest
judicial authority in the land is at
least consistent with his opinion a year
later that he should stay on as mayor of
New York even after his term of office
expired because to hell with democracy
he was the only one
who could handle the post 9/11 crisis so
much for mr. Giuliani Trump debate guest
Sarah Palin / a Washington Post reporter
Trump will only accept a legitimate
election and anything else would betray
those who died for freedom as was said
eight years ago so still it must be said
that woman is an idiot so much for half
Governor Palin and as noted here
yesterday we are approaching the point
at which this country will say so much
for the Republican Party it has long
been anticipated that the runaway train
quality of the Trump campaign would
eventually claim as its collateral
damage all or most of the GOP and its
leaders but that was always considered
to be an event that would hit on
Election Day or thereafter like the
purge of Barry Goldwater's people from
that party in the months after his
landslide loss to Lyndon Johnson in 1964
but this train crashed in Las Vegas
Wednesday night Trump's third public
refusal to recognize the cornerstone of
this or any other democracy you accept
the electoral outcome move this from
political embarrassment to fatal
political infamy to the Republican
leaders I ask again
when will you disavow this
anti-democratic demagogue
when will you defund him when will you
deny him Conway's sessions Giuliani
Palin Chris Christie Mike Pence Corey
Lewandowski Roger stone these people are
done in this country's politics who's
next
Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell who else will
this madman Trump take down this is not
a presidential candidate losing an
election by 537 shaky votes out of 105
million cast after a recount mandated by
state law and the intervention of the
Supreme Court this is not a procedural
dispute over an election already
completed this is the presidential
nominee of the Republican Party refusing
to promise that he will accept the
results of the election 20 days before
the election this is the moral
equivalent of treason when Republican
leaders will you speak up speak up not
in your self-interest
not as a strategic move for your own
campaign not as positioning for the
future when will you speak up for the
Constitution when will you speak up for
the democracy when will you speak up for
the United States of America